all right
e4 well we're playing aggressively with
black
and what does that entail
let's play sicilian i don't know what's
sicilian but
we're going to play a sicilian for sure
um
it's a computer movie it's cheating for
sure e4 is a surefire sign
uh and d4 come on this guy is cheating
let's take it and it looks like a smith
moor is on the cards
let's check
[Music]
yes smith moore so
what do i recommend against this myth
mora for
people who don't want to get checkmated
there's a couple of ways to decline it i
don't recommend accepting it
uh schools no this is perfect don't
worry but i can't chat because i have
this account but
uh but this is perfect now
you guys are giving uh very interesting
ideas but
the best move that i've run into that
doesn't involve taking the pawn
is actually knight f knight f6 there
comes the actually again that f6
you're developing your knife you're
counter attacking the e4 pawn
and uh and
white essentially has to transpose into
an elephant sicilian by playing e5
why don't i recommend taking the pawn i
it's not that it's bad it's just that
smith moral players generally like it
when uh when you go into those main
lines and it really is very very
dangerous to take the pawn
legitimately black has to know a lot
uh to not get crushed assuming that
white knows his stuff so bishop d3
squeals decides not to go e5
and this changes the situation a little
bit because in the smith mora
the bishop comes out to c4 when the
bishop is on d3 it's quite passive
it stares at the pawn and so now we take
the pawn we have a better version
of this myth more still dangerous we
still need to be careful
but the bishop being on d3 really puts a
damper on
the amount of activity that white can
have in return for the pawn
now what should we do how do we how do
we proceed
well in the same way that we normally do
some of you want to play e5 here
understandable but as i'll explain after
the game
it weakens the d5 square everybody
should kind of see that so white can
play bishop g5
trade that night off and perhaps
position his knight on this outpost
so instead let's begin with a flexible
developing move knight c6
let's begin with a flexible developing
move knight c6 then we'll play d6
and as we often do when we've got these
two pawns in the city we address the
question of this bishop
typically by fianchettoing it although
we'll see let's go d6 to prevent him
from going e5
to prevent it from going e5
and generally in the moral the bishop is
on c4 at this point
which really changes the landscape
completely because white has moves like
e5 there's the d file that's open
here we can breathe easily how h3 is
good
stopping the bishop from coming out to
g4 and
we have a couple of options here we can
play it conservatively we can play e6
and bishop e7 um
you know or we can play it um
i was gonna say we could play it
conservatively we can play it liberally
and then
the people playing e6 and g6 will hate
each other for the rest of their
existence
now in this particular instance e6 is
good
when there is an urgency to our
development
uh here there is no urgency to our
development so we might as well
we might as well go g6 bishop g7 because
e5 is not possible we can afford to
um we can afford to optimize the
position of our bishop
all right
and that is how daniel nerd is he
started a civil war in the chat
okay
all right bishop g7
now we want a castle what about the
libertarian move
the libertarian daniel don't tell me
where i should develop my bishop
i'm leaving it on f8 all right
oh god my battery is low so let me
charge my headphones so i can hear him
okay
bishop g5 um
all right well this doesn't threaten the
night we don't have to move the knight
we we have a couple of options here and
the fight there is a five head move here
the five head move is also
a move that perhaps some of you want to
play habitually
uh you can castle but what move can you
play after bishop g5 what what's often
the question do you play this move or do
you not
right h6 there's always a debate do you
play h6 under what circumstances
and uh follow the logic this way if you
castle
white has the very typical plan of going
queen d2
followed by bishop h6 uh in order to
trade
the dark square bishop we don't want to
trade the dark squared bishop that
leaves our king side with weaknesses
this is our strongest piece so by first
playing h6 while our rook is still here
we get the bishop off this diagonal then
if we want to castle
we don't have to worry about this idea
but maybe we won't want a castle maybe
we'll want to keep our king in the
center and actually go after
his castle king goes bishop e3
uh okay
let's castle let's let's play it
conventionally
you might look at this and say well
doesn't this even doesn't this make
queen d2 even stronger
and if he plays it which i think he will
to the rescue comes
a very natural very important very
important move without this move
the entire idea of going h6 doesn't work
we bring our king to h7
supporting the pawn if we play g5 that's
just a little bit too weakening
the king is quite safe on h7 the pawn
protects against this check
you have to be careful about this pin in
the future but right now
there's nothing that he can do about it
there's a pawn chain g6 is protected
we're fine
remember this this uh
this defensive method as a way of
preserving
as a way of preserving your bishop it's
not ideal it often leads to
annoying tactical opportunities like
bishop nigeria five check as i said
but it's still quite solid most of the
time
now we don't want to go e5 because that
would blunt our bishop
and it would still weaken this d5 square
instead
let's address the question of our bishop
and let's come out
to e6 a square that you usually want to
stay away from
right but that's when your bishop's on
fe when your bishop's being kettled
this is a great way of positioning your
bishops you don't need the e-pawn right
now
so it's okay to sit on it for a bit and
the bishop is nicely centralized it
controls the d5 square
you've got good development we're up
upon slight edge for black here
but squeals playing super solid and uh
and pretty good chess
and in these kinds of solid positions
it's important not to do anything too
crazy
we want to act in a in a measured way uh
to improve our position we have
several ways of doing that we can we
have many good moves here
but let's start with a pretty impartial
move that we can all agree
is is a solid one let's go rook to c8
let's activate our rook
contest the c file why not
no you know not reinventing the wheel
here
probably not the best move but a very
solid one for sure
it's hard to make progress and hopefully
this is what i'm trying to illustrate
when you're not sure how to make
progress a lot of people freak out
but in many situations you have this
pool of
pretty reasonable improving moves that
you can tap into
which is where my vastly overused
expression
not every one of your moves has to be
climbing mount everest comes from
you can make moves like rook c8 safe in
the knowledge that
they're probably not going to hurt you
when are we pushing d5 some of you are
noticing that we have a pawn break
that we can make use of which
will probably open up the center i don't
know who benefits from that
to be fair because d5 also opens up his
bishop as you guys can see
and maybe leads to more um acute
tactical opportunities so it's i don't
think it's a bad idea to consider d5
even
this position but i don't see the
necessity of rushing with that i like
the center being a little bit more
closed
rook e1 good move activating the rook
okay
um
knight d7 by jabel very interesting move
actually i quite like it
knight d7 would lift the knight around
either to e5 or to c5
and it would open up the diagonal for
the bishop
that's a lovely move another good move
is to consider to continue looking
around the board and saying well
what little improving moves can we make
what small
but substantive you know actions can we
undertake
to make our position healthier and to do
that
it's it's good to make some observations
some of you notice ah the b3 square
maybe we can we can get our knight there
but if we play knight a5 that puts the
knight on the rim he can slide his
knight to d4
we shouldn't do that just yet which is
why jabel's move knight d7
is so good because it covers the d4
square and it recruits
this knight and will play this move it
recruits this knight potentially
to be the one to aim for b3 so there's
no negative to this
i like the move knight d7 queen a5 would
have also been good
once again there's two key lessons in
this stage of the game the first being
moves like rook c8
you should embrace the second being um
what was i i already forgot what the
second was it was related to the move
knight d7
plans improving moves
climbing mount everest yeah this thought
completely escaped me
no it's not that it's the fork there
were two
aspects to playing this position the
first being
um yeah small improvements but i'll
remember what the second one was later
it tells you how important it is knight
to e2 now he's trying to bring the
knight over to f4 that's also a good
move
very very good play
so this is where um
again we have a series oh i remember the
point
we need to be careful we need to adapt
to the situation what should we do
knight c5 is possible
but potentially leads to the loss of a
pawn so
where else can we go with the knight
what should we do how should we adapt to
this
yeah 95 let's go 95 that's the secondary
idea
behind 97. but aren't we blocking the
bishop again didn't i just say that one
of the advantages of knight d7 was to
unlock there's not blocking it again
not that simple right because this
knight on e5
is not going to remain there for very
long it's either going to take the
bishop that's a pretty important bishop
or it's going to move on to c4
so i'm betting on the fact that we're
probably not going to remain on e5 for
very much longer
okay let's go and i take c5
indeed if he moves his bishop way knight
c4 will be very very strong
some of you i know are anxiously looking
at this a7 pawn this was by design
we're not actually losing a pawn um
for several reasons and even if we were
this would not be the worst pawn to lose
i'm kind of doing this deliberately and
white isn't a tough spot
right because he either has to give away
this bishop which means no more
shenanigans against the king or
he must allow the knight to come to c4
what should squish do squills should
give up the bishop you should go bishop
to d4 here that's a very high level move
thinking ahead and saying well when this
trade is undertaken
uh i want this bishop to lose its
effectiveness now what should we take
with that's also a good move for it it
takes rook
what should we take with not an obvious
question folks
let's think just because i said that you
think bishop
i like taking with the i like taking
with both pieces actually
but but let's let's make the
positionally conscious move take the
bishop
if we take with the queen we allow rook
c1 with tempo he controls the c file
so not that that's bad we can then just
go d7
but i just want to show you that
particular logic in addition
the bishop on e6 might have been
susceptible to a move like knight d4
hitting the bishop perhaps we could even
reroute it to b7 in order to hit the
e4 pawn we lost some control of c4
but we still have enough control of it
to play knight c4
and this was an inaccuracy bishop c2
well i'd even call it a mistake white's
position here is worse he doesn't have
sufficient compensation
but bishop d4 uh the position is very
much
tenable and we'll discuss this after the
game school is playing at a very high
level overall
[Music]
another interesting moment what should
we take here well
from a material perspective we should
take the pun
from the perspective of eliminating
white's best pieces
we can seriously consider taking the
bishop
um i'm kind of torn to be
totally frank uh but let's take the plan
i'm feeling
quite greedy today i need some dessert
to my phone
yeah yeah
this would have been pogba with this
uncontested bishop that could have then
taken b2
but i'm banking on the fact that his
queen has no good squares
his queen has no good squares if it
comes to d2 we'll go back to c4 we'll
have our cake and eat it too then we'll
take the bishop and we'll be up two
pawns
if his queen goes to b3 well then we can
consider bishop e6
so okay he does go queen b3
we could consider bishop b6 the problem
is that this pawn is going to hang um
i did see that but to be completely fair
i
myself underestimated a little bit
that's okay
because i see something clever let's go
here anyway
yes remember what some people forget
it's kind of oxymoron but what some
people forget is that when there's a
queen on b7
we frame this in terms of trapping right
can i trap the queen
uh and oftentimes the answer is no we
don't have the resources
but a queen like this can also be used
as a tool to trade queens if a queen
trade is good for you
thank you they hear a list then a
vulnerable queen can not only be
attacked by other pieces but it can be
quote unquote attacked by a queen
to force a desirable queen trade which
you might want
if you're up a pawn for example or you
want control of a file
what about control of the c file ladies
and gentlemen we hit the bishop we hit
the queen
we force the trade we'll be up a pawn
and we'll have massive uh domination
over the queen side because of our you
know all of our pieces are
nicely poised for the end game i hope
that concept makes sense i think it's an
important one note that the bishop
defended the knight
so and he can't take this pawn either
before or after the queen drink because
the bishop on c2 will be hanging
i just hung my queen that's that's right
oh the oh this guy queen b6 yeah queen
b6 was not possible
queen a5 was possible and let me write
this down
but there was a reason i didn't like it
and i'll show that after the game
i'm excited to talk to squirrels put
somebody on the spot reveal my true
colors
okay
all right it's a battery good move
squill's playing very well um
and now we need to take stock again we
need to realize that our pawn on a7 is
hanging and because it's the end game
the significance of hanging pawns uh
is not trivial we need to defend this or
we need to
do something about it so knight d3 is a
good thought but remember that the rook
is protected
bishop c4 is a great move attacking the
knight but let's play clinically let's
play
a5 why not a6
because in an uh in the future we might
want to drive this pawn to a4 to fix
the weakness of the pawn on a3 alright
and oh we have some cool tactics here
but they don't quite work
yeah they don't going to work so do we
want to give away the bishop we
certainly do not let's keep it
i'll i'll talk about that cory thank
good eyes but uh but that doesn't work
okay now it's time for us to turn the
dial up on the pressure
his position is clearly flimsy but
what can we actually do oh we have a
five head tactic now earlier
what you guys might have noticed is that
there was the possibility of playing
bishop takes d4
bishop d4 and knight d3 attacking the
rook
but then if you're following white had
to move rook to d1
attacking the knight how has this move
changed
this entire dynamic well if you think
about all the king is on f1 now
so what's going to be different at the
end of all of this ah the king's gonna
be here
the rook's gonna be here so we're gonna
have a pin with rook b5 okay
now we need to play fast here because
i'm a little down on the clock he does
correctly give up the exchange
squeals is really good uh he's put up a
phenomenal fight
but the fight comes to an end here we're
up in exchange and a pawn
so we're just going to finish this one
off bishop c4
asking for the bishop trade if he
doesn't yeah he does it
okay now what's the winning method here
well one of them is just to vacuum up as
many pawns as possible we're gonna take
this one
and now we're gonna push no need to give
it away
then we're gonna walk our rook back to
a2 and take this one and promote it
simple we we we don't even have to give
up any pawns we
we could but if you can defend pawn so
easily
okay rook b3 a3
and now very clinical moves to play f6
protecting this pawn
he gives up his bishop okay he doesn't
we could even make a night here let's
move our rook back notice that i'm not
rushing to promote
a trick for time scrambles folks people
promoted the first
opportunity possible you don't have to
do that sometimes you can move the rook
and facilitate the checkmate check and
checkmate great game squeals and now
it's time for the debrief
uh squeals can you add me on discord let
me know first of all phenomenal game
and now the moment everyone's been
waiting for i'm uh
excited about this we're gonna do a call
with squirrels where we go over the game
um i'll invite i'll invite him to an
analysis board so just one
moment all right
squeeze let me know if you can find me
on uh on discord and add me
hey dania can you hear me yep it's
good to meet you yeah it's good to meet
you as well
um i wanted to say first that i'm like
super stoked that like i gotta play a
game with you and
a big fan of the stream been uh watching
for a couple years now so
yeah i really appreciate the opportunity
of course and uh thanks for agreeing to
come on as payment uh just your social
security number credit card information
would be enough
and i think we'd all be satisfied yeah
are you looking for my mother's maiden
name as well that
you know i'm not gonna force not gonna
pressure you on that but you know
just uh that it would be nice to just
kind of see if you if you don't want to
get banned from my stream
no no i i totally understand like i
think it's completely reasonable so
all right well thanks again for for
making time let me invite you to
do an analysis board hopefully it works
oh so i learned um i so i thought i was
up at dj in hours because it's three
o'clock where i'm at but
if it's five rear i don't even i don't
know what that makes you
and um there has to be a new term
invented
uh that that post post degen yep
great so smith moore i think was a great
choice
i haven't faced it too many times so
it's i was kind of happy
have you encountered knight f6 too many
times are you uh
and you don't have to reveal any opening
info because i know everybody's waiting
to prepare for you
are you a smith or a regular were you
just experimenting
let me let me tell you this so i
actually um
as far as like the smith moor goes i
don't really know any theory at all the
only time i've encountered this was one
game against
i played uh the count
um and he played the same thing and
that's the only time i've seen it before
so i kind of just was yeah just so my
main goal was just to kind of
maybe play something solid and just try
to not blunder any pieces
and that's kind of where i went with it
right no that that makes sense and that
f6 is not
very cooperative because yeah most
smithmore players like to see dc
yes um and you know my goal is to be
maximally annoying but this what this
forces white to do i mean if you're the
main theoretical move is e5 here
um and this transposes into the alpha
and sicilian black
has to move the knight and this position
usually arises
via the move c3 which i played with
white before
on on the speed run and then one of
black's main moves is here
and you get the same position by
transposition
um but the the good thing about playing
this with black is that the positions
that occur are
quite a bit less tactical and explosive
than in the smith mora
although they're still full of life so i
i would
totally recommend for you to look into
this line with white and then white can
go knight f3
um so that's a theoretical line but it's
definitely still fun
sweet yeah yeah i've messed around with
the aloe pin like
like quite a while ago like a few months
ago i never really like learned anything
in the theory about it but it definitely
seems like a good alternative if i don't
want to
do something quite as crazy right and if
you learn and then
in this position e5 is you know it's
just natural because you're you're
already gonna know it
so the one drawback of this of course
compared to this myth more is that the
bishop
is generally on c4 on the smith mora
right
yeah i was gonna mention that actually
yeah that's a good point and it's
it's interesting how i think in gambits
particularly
the placement of one piece can make all
the difference uh because
that difference in placement can prevent
uh very important tactics from being
possible so
the way that the game went i think i
think you played you know as
close as it comes to ideal development
h3 was good
to stop bishop g4 i could afford to make
this move g6
uh but in the smith mora what's really
interesting is that
we just make the regular smith mora
moves
so takes if i play the same way that i
did here
already at this point um but
particularly in this position
can you spot a pretty strong tactical
idea for one and
maybe you're familiar with it a strong
tactical idea for white so
i'm not too familiar i do know that
there are some some tricks with like
some bishop takes
f7 that's exactly right
is that actually it here it not
immediately but if you open the d
file the queen might land in trouble
given that the king is
uh you know it's it's in an affair with
the f7 pawn so then let's go with the e5
e5 is absolutely right and the thing is
if i play knight takes e5
you take and now as you can see the king
is yeah
yeah exactly bishop f7 and you can make
moves
if you want these lines with white oh
okay yeah i do know this
i do know this trick here like i see
sometimes when they don't develop the
night out um
early enough to protect the queen
sometimes this idea is possible for me
to
do that but right people did it i wish
people would let me do it more
yeah it's one of those things that that
makes these gamuts appealing is how many
of these there are but of course black
can play d takes e5
uh and avoid this but the fact is and
i'm not a specialist so maybe i'm
missing the market but even in the end
game it's the king
is is weak black is underdeveloped and
after knight takes d8
you can strike with knight to b5 you can
see how unpleasant this becomes right
knight is coming here
the fact that it's an end game doesn't
mean that white doesn't have attacking
chances i think black's in trouble here
and it you know king d8 then in
goodnight g5
this is always a funny line and you're
like the mirror yeah
800 forks so anyways long story short
all of this is possible because the
bishop's on c4 and the d-file is open
so compared to this position i'm able to
take these luxuries and so that's why i
think black is
is doing pretty well here
um now this stage you played great
bishop g5 is
is perfect i played h6 uh so that after
castles
what were you planning to do here yeah
i'm i'm
i was just gonna do this and try to
trade off the bishop of course
which is exactly right which is uh and
the chat can
can now see like this is exactly what i
tried to stop with h6
um bishop b3 was good because you're not
allowing g5 with tempo um and queen e2
was good
at least getting the king onto a
slightly more vulnerable spot
and now i love that you played rook ac1
which is patient you're bringing the
rook into the game
and the move that i thought maybe was
not entirely necessary was a3 was your
idea
sorry was your idea to prepare before or
were you worried about
the pawn becoming weak so there's like a
couple reasons
behind it one was that i wanted to make
sure that my
with my mobility as well as um
i just know that it's like really common
to bring this like night here and go
after the bishop
and so i just wanted to kind of make
sure that
you weren't able to do that um because
again like i was trying to play solid
and just like try to not trade off as
many pieces
as i could because i know that maybe
once you trade off like there's a lot of
pieces it might be a little easier for
you right
well didn't you get the memo that i suck
the less pieces there on the board the
more i suck
i don't think that's the truth that
should have been your motto but
i think this is a very reasonable
intention
thanks ketherian for the prime uh now
first of all specifically let's let's
say that night before wasn't a concern
what sort of general improving move
could you could you make
if you weren't worried about something
like night before
what seems reasonable as a as a
follow-up to rook ac1
um maybe i could get my other rook
involved
or yeah that's what i was thinking i
would
i would get it to d1 so it stacks up
with the queen
and if you think about the long run
right so let's say rook fd1
let's say i play the same way i played
rook c8 and you move your queen away
you're already creating this standoff
and combined with the fact that the
bishop has an x-ray against the king
our good old friend e5 might come
knocking on black's door again
right so this creates some issues for
black
but the thing is knight b4 is actually
not particularly scary in these
positions
because you can go bishop to b1 and this
is a super important resource
in a lot of situations where there's a
knight like this
this bishop is super safe that's what
makes bishops great they can be on b1
and do the same thing they do from d3
and then you're just going to go a3 and
push the knight away or
you're going to use this knight to your
favorites undefended it's x-rayed by the
queen
and guess what it's no longer protecting
the e5 square
so e5 already is sort of a semi threat
if that makes sense yeah yeah that makes
sense
so one of the lessons here for your
games is uh
if you identify a move that at first
makes you feel uneasy
um if you think a little bit if you can
determine that that move isn't
actually scary you can provoke your
opponent into playing it because a lot
of people in the
14 1500 range will be tempted to play
this move
and if that turns out to be a waste of
time people will often not consider the
drawbacks of a move like knight before
i.e the fact that it relinquishes
central control
because it seems to be doing so much
if that makes sense so sure yeah yeah i
think a lot of
players like at my level they really
don't like they
they don't think that far ahead and i
think it'd be good for like me to
be kind of thinking about some ways to
like set some traps uh like that you
know
to maybe like lure the knight out here
so that
um i could use it like for like a trick
later to because it's an undefended
piece
right or put or worse some source push
away yeah people people are biased in
favor of these
quote-unquote active moves that uh that
cross the
the hemisphere um so you can use them
as a as a powerful way of not only
setting traps but yeah making your
opponent go in the wrong direction and
take the focus away from the center for
example so in any case not
not a huge deal but it also gives me the
square potentially for my knight
uh which i which i kind of like and that
was the idea of 97
which where i wanted to bring the knight
here and then potentially to b3 so i
really liked your move
knight e2 uh taking
you know maybe you didn't play with that
specific intention but it does
uh discourage me from going knight
knight c5 because you're defending that
uh with the rook now oh okay yeah i'll
be honest i didn't
see that i my main goal was just to like
kind of like protect these two squares
and then i also even thought about like
bringing it here and maybe going for a
king side attack
perhaps even to have five yeah this idea
of knight f4 is quite nasty
so i know i like that move a lot and so
that's why
i sort of decided to change to change my
approach
and i really thought that the critical
moment the moment when
things uh took a turn for the worse
came rook takes c is fine because if we
take c
you can go rook c one with tempo yeah
um this i think was yeah and i think
this was the pivotal moment actually
because
you're in an unpleasant dilemma you can
either give me the c4 square
or you have to give away the bishop that
potentially creates chances against the
king
and i assume that did you spot knight c4
and
consider queen before queen d3 to be
the sort of lesser evil than giving away
the bishop
no i guess my main thing here is i
didn't really like think about what you
wanted to do i just thought about like
i'm excited to trade off my bishop and i
just wanted to maybe bring it to a
different
i am the most important person here so
not thinking about what i want is
this represents how toxic this community
is
so this is definitely a
uh a situation which leads to a lot of
mistakes uh where
you know there's all these variables
that you have to account for
but assuming that you have to give up
the bishop
what the way you want to think about
this position is okay
let's imagine that queen knight d3 queen
d3 is on the board
what stuff do i want to do in this
position so that
the transition isn't as uh isn't as
painful can i take the sting
out of any of the things that will that
will ensue
following the trade and that leads you
to a good move in this position
so i see that after you do that you
would be threatening to take this pawn
so maybe i could like just push
before something you're on the right
track but you could nip this whole
thing in the butt it's not just the pawn
that's being threatened this bishop is
um is having a great time
oh then maybe bishop bingo bingo bishop
d4
is is i think the classy move because
yeah knight d3 you take the knight
and you're only down upon i have no good
move other than to take your bishop if i
go e5
well i've weakened all of this stuff in
the pawn i'm not gonna do that
but if i take what would you take with
here
something let me see either the queen or
the knight
let me give you a huge hit sure what
does your instinct say
my instinct says the knight so that my
red could be
like activated a little i agree i agree
i think knight takes this good
centralizing and
yeah e5 is an idea later on so you're
very much in the game here
and that's the key takeaway i think you
if you've accepted something as a
reality like i have to give up this
piece
you make this preparatory move to uh to
deal with the
the consequences that will be true after
the traitor after the
that stuff happens okay yeah that makes
sense i like that
because here yeah i take another pawn
then i gave it back to
to get all my pieces and enforce an end
game and this end game is
is unfortunately very very unpleasant
for you because i've just got all my
pieces on
ideal squares essentially and your
bishop is sort of dangling
yeah and you know you did what you good
i thought rook c1 was
was uh was the best move you could have
played and
in order to prolong the game you're
definitely close to being lost here
i think that you have to probably move
the bishop back
and try to get a rook trade which is not
good for you in the grand scheme of
things
but this pin is you know a potential
problem which is kind of what happened
in the game yeah
so i think this would have would have
offered some chances
after 94 bishop d7 yeah this was
unfortunately
for you yeah this this arrangement would
have allowed bishop e5
which you spotted and you made the most
resilient move but
we've got a little too much material at
this point oh yeah
yep totally spotted that all right
you calculated that in just just a
couple of moments
uh so yeah this queen ca was a bit of a
lucky resource because at first
i was gonna play queen a5 to to attack
the rook
now if i had done that where do you
think you should place your brook
well my initial instinct is just to
attack the knight yeah and that's
absolutely right
rook b1 and then if i drop the knight to
c4 you could perhaps take this spawn or
this pawn and
you're you're still in the game okay um
so
yeah once once i did this the the
situation kind of kind of takes a turn
so really i think
there were two key takeaways bishop d3
i would say your level is not you know
not a bad move
to get a smith more alike position but
the fact that the bishop is done on c4
gives me this chance
to develop pretty pretty normally um
and then i think you played great moves
a3 was a bit of an inaccuracy so asking
yourself
is the quote-unquote unpleasant move
actually a threat or can i use it to my
advantage
and then uh how can i prepare for
something unpleasant that's probably
going to happen you identify the bishop
and you kind of preemptively put your
bishop to contestant i think you're
still in
pretty decent shape here so that was a
really hard-fought game you could see
how much time i used i mean
basically all of it yeah i was like
i was like pleasantly surprised that i
was able to bring it down to like kind
of at least like an end game or
close to it so that was that was good no
i can tell your your fundamentals are
very solid here
you know moves like rook ac one telling
me that you you know you know what
you're doing in
in any given middle game position so so
that was great
um any any questions that you had or
thought for us
that you wanted to talk through i feel
like i've been i've been uh running off
of the mouth
so no you know you're good it's been a
yeah a lot of good learning things so
maybe the only thing that i think um
that i would just be a little bit so
like i was debating a long time
around like move 14 kind of what my
where's my
back here a little bit uh one moment
yeah i was like right here i was really
unsure
like because i know in like the smith
moore you since i'm like down upon i'm
trying to go for like
an initiative and stuff and like i was
even considering doing some stuff like
that but i was like worried about sex
and like not having it now lead to
anywhere so like
um what should like a game plan be if
like i don't feel like i have some sort
of
initiative per se yeah this is a great
that's a great question
i'll say two things you're right to
think g4 is
taking it a little too far although
thinking about such a move is great
and then some this is a move you'd play
if you were really desperate if you were
like down a piece here
i would consider g4 but given that
you're down a pawn you can afford a more
measured approach and this is where i
think
this move uh would give more of a more
of an opportunity because
what makes this move confusing is when
you're not playing on the king's side
how does this help
but you actually kind of are indirectly
with the plan that i'd
outlined previously where you can now
move your queen away from from d2
and you do you see what white is
threatening now let's say i go b5
i'm actually not sure i do so if you
think about what queen e2
accomplishes it opens up an x-ray
against against black's queen
if the d6 pawn were were be made to
disappear you would have a discovery
yeah bingo okay and so you actually are
using
the position of white black skin to your
advantage just in an indirect way
yeah exactly exactly so that would be
one idea
but if you wanted to play more directly
on the king's side
um a plan that you can consider in such
scenarios again trying to capitalize on
this diagonal is is saying well if i had
this pawn on f5
maybe that would help break down some of
the defenses in black's position
so even a move like knight h2 it's not
my favorite move it's slow
but in the absence of other ideas this
idea pushing the f-pawn
could be a good compromise and this is
where what i said in the in the previous
game
um when you've got your kingside pawns
pushing the f pawn is gonna be the least
weakening
of the three between the h the g and the
f puns they're not all the same
so if you want a plan that involves
weakening your king a little bit
particularly if you have a bishop here
moving the f pawn might be a pretty safe
bet
okay yeah this is actually a move this
is one of my candidate moves i would say
like
top two or three that i was like looking
at in this position
um but i was just yeah like because i
was like wanting to do this
right and go go over here but i was just
a little bit worried about
opening up my king against the gm you
know
well yeah i would have just just sacked
everything on g4 and in this specific
position
something like d5 is very good for black
but i'm sort of outlining the general
approach to take and no i thought you
played you played solid you played
really good and uh
really it was it was a couple of very
small small things that that accumulated
so
that was that was a great game i hope i
mean i hope you found this
at least a little bit instructive and
and fun
yeah definitely definitely more than a
little bit i really appreciate it
um it was a good game thank you good on
you to say that because if you hadn't
said anything else you would that would
have been your last day in the stream
of course of course well i won't keep
you any longer i know it's probably
late and and thank you so much for uh
for agreeing to come on uh this was this
was a lot of fun for me and
uh you know i'll definitely give you
give you a chance at a rematch
at some point in the near future i'd
appreciate that i'm looking forward to
it
of course thanks man how about have a
good one okay
thank you as well we'll see you yeah see
ya
it's so funny because now schools will
be in the chat i think i feel like
there's this meta transformation of
of mediums of communication but in all
seriousness
huge thank you schools yeah you're i can
tell you're super chill and
not only did you play really really good
but i appreciate
you hopping on now and i know there were
a lot a lot of people willing to
to come on so that was that was great i
think that went pretty well
that went really well and uh the game
itself was super rich as well